all right so what is going on here
joining us with more former senior
advisor to president trump stephen
miller is with us
um i watched the last three weeks and
it's frankly uncomfortable
but we are talking about i believe the
hardest job in the world
uh we need a president that is strong
that has mental alertness
mental acuity physical stamina for the
demands of the job
you were with donald trump all four
years uh
do you see as i do a difference between
joe
circa 2012 2016 and today
he's not the same person he's not even a
shadow of the person he used to be
if you watch the address that he gave
last night sean it was painful to watch
him read through it
i mean he barely was able to make it
through
it was so dour so gloomy
so sullen there was no energy he was
trying to rally the country
that speech wouldn't even give you
enough energy to walk down a flight of
stairs
i mean there was there was no enthusiasm
in it this was supposed to be his big
moment
to get the country rallied to kill the
virus
to end the pandemic and the speech put
you to sleep
and on top of that there was one passage
in the speech
that shows how profoundly disconnected
joe biden is from reality
biden said in the speech that if we all
get vaccinated
if we do everything right if we wear a
mask and we keep the economy closed down
then maybe just maybe by july 4th we can
have dinner in our own backyards with
our own family members
does joe really not know is he so out of
touch
that he doesn't know that families have
been dining with each other
and with their loved ones for months now
does he not know that
let me ask you about the process cause
i've known donald trump over 25 years
uh he has more energy
than probably a hundred average people i
mean i've never seen anything like it i
know you
you dealt with it you were as chief
speechwriter
tell me if this if my observation was
correct that
he would give you the speech he would
dictate it basically
and then you would craft it put it all
together
and throughout that process oh i want
you to add this take this out put this
in at that at this
and then when he actually gave the
speech the hardest job for
anybody in the white house was running
his teleprompter because he never stayed
on script
true or false
it's it's completely true donald trump
was intimately involved in every word
every sentence every phrasing
and every speech that he gave he he
owned it
every part of donald trump's personality
and vision was
exuding from the speeches that he was
giving by contrast when you hear joe
biden talk
what do you hear at home you hear his
young progressive age
you don't hear joe biden you hear the
people behind the curtain
that's the fundamental issue sean that's
the public health issue that's the
national security issue
that's the economic security issue who
are who are the young progressive aides
that are pushing all of these crazy
policies i mean for example take the
teachers union why didn't joe biden
stand up last night to teachers unions
and say open our schools now
because the people working for joe biden
don't want that to happen
so he's not the one making the decisions
that's
deeply alarming sean all right stephen
miller thank you
thanks for being with us when we